[Musik]
herzlich willkommen noch wird fußball
gespielt bald schon aber beginnen die
olympischen sommerspiele in japan der
traditionelle fackellauf startete
bereits und zwar in fukushima also genau
da wo vor zehn jahren die
nuklearkatastrophe stattfand heute
wollen wir uns den gefahren des
atomzeitalters widmen nicht nur der
atomkraft sondern auch den unzähligen
atomwaffen die weltweit immer noch
einsatzbereit sind
denn japan das auch dasjenige land das
1945 zwei atombombenabwürfen zum opfer
fiel nämlich in hiroshima und nagasaki
eine aktuelle von der seg koproduzierte
web dokumentation mit dem titel nuclear
games geht den diversen atomaren
gefahren nach von der geschichte bis in
die gegenwart
auf der webseite finden sie dazu
filmsequenzen grafiken und
hintergrundmaterial auf dass ich im
folgenden immer wieder bezug nehmen
müssen wir in zukunft mit den gefahren
der kernspaltung leben einerseits um
klimafreundlichen strom zu produzieren
nämlich in kernkraftwerken
andererseits aber auch um kriege zu
verhindern dank der abschreckung durch
atomwaffen oder haben wir mit der
atombombe und eine radioaktivität etwas
geschaffen dass unseren menschlichen
horizont bei weitem übersteigt und uns
als gesamte menschheit vernichten könnte
über diese fragen sprechen ich mit anna
die platzes sie ist philosophin und
ethikerin an der universität zürich und
beschäftigt sich mit umweltethik
bioethik und dem verhältnis von mensch
natur und technik und herr trainers
oliver thränert ist politologe und
sicherheitsexperte und leiteten
thinktank am center for security studies
an der eth zürich und da ist ein
international gefragter experte wenn es
um atomwaffen abschreckung und um
abrüstung geht herzlich willkommen in
beiden herzlich willkommen schön hier zu
sein
der trainer hat es gibt ein gremium das
jahr für jahr schätzt wie wahrscheinlich
es ist
dass es zu einem atomkrieg kommt und
diese expertinnen und experten meinen es
steht heute 100 sekunden vor zwölf
der weltuntergang ist so nahe wie schon
lange nicht mehr
das ist ziemlich beunruhigend für mich
zumindest für mich auch es gibt
verschiedene gründe für diese
einschätzung und ich denke es gibt
eigentlich zwei dimensionen die man hier
sich anschauen muss zum einen gibt es
eine dimension der sich intensivieren
denn großmächte konkurrenz und zwar
nicht mehr nur bilateral zwischen den
usa und russland wie während des kalten
krieges sondern wir haben auch eine
dimension mit china das nuklear
aufrüstet das heißt das ganze ist schon
zu einem zu einem dreiklang geworden usa
russland china
wir haben aber darüber hinaus auch
weitere nukleare akteure die über
atomwaffen verfügen und ihre
atomwaffenarsenale massiv ausbauen was
die wenigsten wissen prozentual
dasjenige atomwaffen system oder
atomwaffen land dass deine seine
arsenale am schnellsten ausbau des
pakistan wiederum mit seinem nachbarn
indien in einem konflikt das auch über
atomwaffen verfügt das ist mal die eine
dimension und die andere dimension ist
die technische dimension
das heißt wir haben eine vielzahl von
technologien die sich sehr schnell
entwickeln die nicht unbedingt nur klare
technologien sind da geht es zum
beispiel um cyber fähigkeiten um
nukleare kommandozentralen angreifen zu
können oder um anti satelliten waffen um
die kommunikation im weltraum
unterdrücken zu können all das hat
einwirkung auf die stabilität von
nuklearer abschreckung diese technologie
geht sehr dynamisch voran in
verschiedenen ländern und insofern würde
ich also auch sagen die lage ist prekär
und man kann sich darüber unterhalten ob
sie sogar noch gefährlicher ist als
während der hochzeit des kalten krieges
oder weniger aber auch auf jeden fall
die dynamik geht in eine richtung wo ich
sagen würde instabilität ist das wort
des tages sozusagen
und das würde ich also insofern teilen
und sie sagen sogar wir sind in eine
neue phase des nuklear
zeitalters an getreten und wir scheinen
uns vielleicht mal in einer grafik die
weltweit die nukleare sprengköpfe die
atombomben so verteilt sind das ist
natürlich immer noch ein erbe des kalten
krieges man sieht nämlich dass russland
und die usa über 20 mal mehr
atomsprengköpfe haben als die restlichen
länder die haben stark reduziert aber es
sind immer noch sehr viele und dann
sieht man china frankreich
großbritannien pakistan dass sie erwähnt
haben indien bis zu israel und nordkorea
und das ist ja das eine die ich die
einfache anzahl aber das andere ist die
die was für arten der waffen dass er da
passiert wenn ich sie richtig verstehe
auch dass so etwas wie eine
modernisierung eine veränderung
gerade sie haben einerseits die
abwehrsysteme genannt die hat mich auch
wichtig sind eine waffe ist nur so stark
wie das gegnerische abwehr system aber
die waffen selbst haben sich auch
verändert können sie das kurz erläutern
ja die atomwaffen sind flexibler
geworden man kann die sprengkraft
flexibel variieren dass zum beispiel
etwas man kann kleinere spreng wirkungen
erzielen wo kritiker dann argumentieren
dass dadurch die atomwaffen sozusagen
einsatzbereiter werden die
wahrscheinlichkeit steigt dass sie auch
tatsächlich eingesetzt werden
auf der seite der trägersysteme für die
atomwaffe tut sie ist sehr viel die
haben wir die russen und die chinesen
haben gearbeitet und hinter breit zu
stationieren sogenannte hyperschall
waffen das sind waffen die mit
mehrfacher schallgeschwindigkeit fliegen
kann und zwar nicht nur in einer
ballistischen kurve sondern in einem
vorher einprogrammierten dann aber immer
noch variabel nach zu steuernden kurs
als er einen manöver das mannheimer und
das genau bedeutet dass der angegriffene
bis kurz vor dem einschlag nicht weiß
welches ziel eigentlich angegriffen
werden soll
und das ist natürlich sehr instabilität
fördernd und dann gibt es eben noch
technologien wie sie es schon gesagt
haben im bereich der raketenabwehr aber
eben auch der anti satelliten waffen der
u boot abwehr alle diese dinge machen
die sozusagen die strategische
stabilität
instabil werden wir konkret ich habe
hier einen roten knopf mitgebracht ist
symbolisch für das auslösen nach der
session atombombe was wäre denn ein
konkretes szenario aus ihrer sicht das
passieren könnte in den nächsten fünf
oder zehn jahren wer könnte diesen korb
knopf drücken und aus welchen gründen
ja das ist natürlich immer so ein
bisschen mit der glaskugel in die
zukunft schauen aber ich denke eines der
größten probleme besteht darin dass
sowohl die russin als auch die chinesen
analysiert haben dass der schwachpunkt
der amerikanischen verteidigungs
konzeptionen die alliierten und die
sogenannte erweiterte nukleare
abschreckung ist also das heißt die
amerikaner versuchen ja mit ihren
kernwaffen nicht nur für sich selbst
nukleare abschreckung herzustellen
sondern auch für die partner in der nato
aber auch für andere alliierte in asien
wie insbesondere japan australien und
südkorea
die selber nicht über kernwaffen das
heißt konkret zu sein in italien oder in
deutschland sind auch atomwaffen
stationiert von den amerikanern also in
unseren nachbarn in italien in
deutschland auch in belgien und in den
niederlanden sowie in der türkei und
diese staaten stellen auch flugzeuge zur
verfügung um diese atomwaffen im
kriegsfall einsetzen zu können
jetzt aber auf das szenario
zurückzukommen was ich angesprochen
haben also da denke ich dass ein
szenario wäre dass es zu einem krieg
kommt oder zu einer militärischen
auseinandersetzung wo es um die
unabhängigkeit von taiwan beispielsweise
geht also die derzeitige chinesische
führung spricht ja eigentlich relativ
stark davon dass man dass man taiwan
wieder sozusagen in den bereich der
volksrepublik china
wie integrieren möchte amerika möchte
das natürlich verhindern weil wenn china
wenn peking dazu in der lage wäre würde
praktisch das gesamte weltweite globale
amerikanische beistands und und allianz
system an glaubwürdigkeit massiv
verlieren und um taiwan dass das nicht
der der wahrscheinlichste konflikt
könnte es zu einem konflikt zwischen
zwischen den usa und china kommen und
der könnte durchaus nuklear eskalieren
es seien kann unter anderem dass die
amerikaner dann nicht diesen diesem
konflikt also ihre niederlage
eingestehen würden oder dass sie
genetische kommandozentralen mit
konventionellen mitteln angreifen die
aber auch für die chinesischen
nuklearwaffen verantwortlich sind so
dass die chinesen glauben hier soll die
nukleare zweite schlag fähigkeit
genommen werden und dann ihrerseits
nuklear lokale zweite schlag fähigkeit
muss man vielleicht erläutern das heißt
dass man sozusagen die antwort die
reaktion liefert wenn man angegriffen
wird es ist die basis der nuklearen
abschreckung das egon bahr hat es früher
mal so gesagt wer als erster fertig
schießt stirbt als weiter dass das ist
sozusagen die grundlage von von
nuklearer abschreckung nuklearer zwei
tragfähigkeit und wenn ich jetzt aber
eine gegnerische kommandozentrale
angreife und die zerstöre ist ja der
angegriffenen nicht mehr in der lage
diese atomwaffen die zwar noch da sind
loszuschicken
und daher sind solche kommandozentralen
die aber eben nicht nur für kernwaffen
sondern auch für konventionelle waffen
da sind immer ein sehr kritischer punkt
ich bin froh haben wir noch eine
ethikerin hier am tisch
es ist ja schon sehr sauer sondern
könnte die menschheit und die erde
mehrfach in die luft sprengen wenn man
diese zahlen sieht und diese geschichten
und ich meine diese atombombe wurde
ursprünglich im zweiten weltkrieg
entwickelt im rahmen des manhattan
project in den usa um den
nationalsozialismus zu bekämpfen und
zweiten weltkrieg für sich zu
entscheiden
wie sehen sie denn das als ethikerin die
idee dass man ein übel konstruiert die
bombe um damit ein anderes übel ein
totalitäres system zu beenden so ja
einen krieg zu gewinnen
ich glaube er hat das sehr schön gezeigt
das problem oder dass man kann man immer
die rechtfertigung für alles wenn der
andere ist ja auch tut wenn anders ja
auch machen und theoretisch kann man das
natürlich sie einfach auch kritisch
diskutieren das geht aber nicht darum
macht die die leute die damals
entschieden haben zu verurteilen dass
das war eigentlich sehr sehr schwierige
situation aber sicher muss man sich
fragen ob eine solche waffe nicht
einfach unverhältnismäßig ist es keine
rechtfertigung gibt eine solche waffe
zu entwickeln mit dem entwickeln hat man
ja dann auch einen schritt gemacht er
eben über die eigentliche
kriegssituation hinausgeht und auch zu
dem damaligen zeitpunkt muss man
natürlich sagen ging man in amerika
davon aus dass die nationalsozialisten
auch an dieser war verarbeiten das war
also wirklich diese rechtfertigung man
hat aber dann ja schon auch gesehen dass
die software dann auch eingesetzt wurde
zu einem zeitpunkt wo ganz klar war dass
der gegner keine solche waffe hatte also
es ist war schon nicht nur das der grund
aber der die idee war sicher ein 1 1
sehr unethisches system zu beenden
aber in solchen szenarien wir dann gerne
werden einfach zwei mann mann mann mann
inszeniert ein dilemma zwischen zwei
möglichkeiten als entweder hat man hat
man das eine übel die hat dass die die
moralische der moralischen untergang
genannt oder man hat die vernichtung
aber tatsächlich gibt es ja immer auch
noch viele zwischenstufen ich glaube
daran muss man denken wenn man wenn man
eben niemand dieses thema im kopf hab
was gibt es für möglichkeiten dazu zu
vermeiden
der philosoph karl jaspers hat von einem
zwei hörnern aktion gesprochen und auch
die atombombe rechtfertigen nicht
gegenüber den den nazis sondern
gegenüber dem kommunismus dann später
das ist interessant aber sie haben sie
gesagt das ist unverhältnismäßig oder
war es war es damals mit sicherheit ein
anderer philosoph der technik britische
philosoph günther anders hat von einer
apokalypse blindheit gesprochen also wir
seien blind gegenüber der
selbstvernichtung aus menschheit
geworden sagt ja damals und wie es die
frage ist wie ist das heute ich meine
wir haben die zahlen gesehen es gibt
noch genügend atomwaffen auf der welt
blenden wir das aus was da eigentlich in
unseren händen ist dass wir uns selbst
das menschheit zerstören können mit
einem knopfdruck
ich glaube nicht ich glaube das
bewusstsein ist schon da und es ist eben
nicht nur in bezug auf atomare waffen
oder mehr die die ich glaube die die
technischen entwicklung in den letzten
50 60 jahren haben auch neue
möglichkeiten aufgezeigt wie die
menschheit sich selbst bedroht also dass
sie hat die ganzen lebensgrundlagen
grundsätzlich zerstört oder auch im
kontext der künstlichen intelligenz gibt
es ja diese szenarien dass man eine
intelligenz konstruieren könnte die uns
selbst bedroht also ich glaube diese
idee dass die technik eine bedrohung
sein könnte die ist schon da aber sie
ist so abstrakt dass man dass man sie
halt einfacher im hinterkopf hat man
lebt man lebt man lebt trotzdem mit dem
wissen was will man auch anderes tun
jetzt gerade bei einem eine bedrohung
wieder automaten bedrohung noch mehr als
jetzt bei der bedrohung durch den
klimawandel hat ja der der einzelne
bürger nicht viele möglichkeiten etwas
dagegen zu tun
sie sind auch biologin nicht nur
philosophen tätigen sondern nach
biologin es gibt ja auch die
biologischen waffen es gibt dabei wären
also wir haben das corona virus ein jahr
lang erdulden müssen
dann gibt es bei der gentechnik auch
immer wieder die frage wie weit man
gehen soll wie sehen sie diesen bereich
sondern gefahren hier ja auch da also
ich meine dass es gibt auch leute die
beispielsweise weil sie sagen die unsere
unglaublichen medizinischen fortschritte
machen und sagen mir mehr abhängig von
der medizin
das heißt wir brauchen die mediziner
auch zu zu um zu überleben und insofern
wenn die medizin ausfällt sind wir sind
wir sehr anfällig also es gibt in
verschiedener hinsicht sind die hand von
der technik abhängig um die technik ist
in gewisser weise kann zu einer
bedrohung werden
ob ich bin das ist spannend in dieser
ganzen diskussion in den technik
fünfziger sechziger siebziger jahren wie
diese idee der der zerstörung der
menschheit als die die absolut größte
bedrohung dargestellt wird also ich muss
sagen ich bin die größte herausforderung
ist sie ist die bedrohung der menschen
außer die einzelnen menschen
das beginnt viel früher aus dann bei
diesem apokalypsen szenario wenn die
ganze menschheit zerstört werden können
dass das kind ist nicht einmal das das
größte ethische problem ehrlich gesagt
ich finde die probleme beginnen
das müssen sie kurz erläutern dass die
menschheit untergeht ist nicht das
größte problem ich denke nicht also als
ethischer perspektive denks unsere
moralischen pflichten sind in
allererster linie ein menschliches leid
zu verhindern
unwürdige existenzen zu verhindern man
kann sagen diese probleme hat man nicht
mehr in die menschheit existiert ich
will das nicht als dass das warum wir
uns in erster linie sorgen machen müssen
betrachten sondern ich glaube unsere
probleme wo wir wirklich etwas tun ist
beginnt viel früher erinnert es gibt ja
eine internationale kampagne zur
abschaffung der atomwaffen insgesamt
diese organisation die hat icann
abkürzung die sitz in genf und wurde
2017 mit dem friedensnobelpreis
ausgezeichnet und die fordert seit
einigen jahren die eine nuklearfreien
welt eine welt ohne atomwaffen
ketzerische frage ist das überhaupt
erstrebenswert oder ist so eine
superwaffe vielleicht auch garantie für
sicherheit und stabilität in einer welt
wo die kleinen in unterschiedlichen
interessenlagen da sind ja das müsste
man wahrscheinlich in zwei teilen
beantworten also zum einen denke ich es
hat natürlich eine gewisse plausibilität
zu sagen die konfrontation zwischen der
sowjetunion dem warschauer pakt
einerseits und den usa der nato den
westlichen lager andererseits wäre
möglicherweise zu einem großen
konventionellen krieg der auch sehr für
verwüstungen und leid und tod mit sich
gebracht hätte er eskaliert wenn es
nicht die nukleare abschreckung gegeben
hätte beweisen kann man das natürlich
nicht weil wir nicht wissen wie die
geschichte ohne atomwaffen gelaufen wäre
das ist mal das eine aber ich denke es
hat eine gewisse plausibilität zu sagen
also dass gerade der schrecken der mit
dem einsatz von atomwaffen zusammenhängt
auch dazu beigetragen hat dass wir seit
1945 keine großen kriege zwischen
großmächten mehr
gesehen haben die andere frage ist
natürlich dass das wäre die these dass
es das ohne atomwaffen aus ihrer sicht
wahrscheinlich mehr kriege gegeben hätte
zwischen groß mächtig ich sage das ist
plausibel aber ich sage zugleich wissen
tue ich es natürlich nicht jetzt ist
natürlich die frage wollen wir mit
dieser situation ewig leben können wir
davon ausgehen da die nukleare
abschreckung in der vergangenheit
funktioniert hat wird sie auch die
nächsten 5000 jahre funktionieren und
das können wir natürlich nicht aus
verschiedenen gründen weil wir nicht
wissen wie sich die mächte konstellation
entwickeln auch wie sich die technik
weiterentwickelt und ob es tatsächlich
gelingt also nukleare abschreckung auf
die dauer stabil zu organisieren und
dann kommen natürlich die frage ja wenn
wir uns darauf nicht verlassen können
dann sollten wir darüber nachdenken
atomwaffen abzuschaffen
in der mittleren des längeren frist der
ehemalige amerikanische präsident barack
obama hat ja im april 2009
da eine große rede vor der prager burg
erhalten wo er sich diesem thema
gewidmet hat und woher also auch die
perspektive eröffnet hat auf atomwaffen
verzichten zu wollen in der längeren
frist und hat aber auch einige
voraussetzungen dafür genannt und die
sind natürlich sehr sehr wichtig und die
werden von der initiative die sie gerade
genannt haben die sich dafür einsetzt
dass atomwaffen verbot dass er von den
vereinten nationen in den vereinten
nationen schon angenommen worden ist und
dem einige staaten schon beigetreten
das war schon in kraft getreten ist dass
sich dieses atomwaffen verbots abkommen
verbreitert und da muss ich sagen da
gibt es aber jetzt bei diesem speziellen
weg der dort jetzt eingeschlagen worden
ist eine reihe von zentralen schwächen
die für mich einfach schlicht
inakzeptabel nämlich ich möchte nicht in
einer welt leben wo ich nicht weiß ob
auch wirklich alle staaten atomwaffen
abgerüstet haben und wo ich auch nicht
weiß ob die zivile nutzung der
kernenergie nicht doch heimlich für den
wieder bau von atomwaffen entwickelt
wird also das argument ist wenn ich sie
richtig verstehe diese abschaffung die
kann man nicht wirklich überprüfen
also wenn ihr aufbauen das nicht
überprüfen kann das weiß ich nicht ich
sage nur dieses abkommen was ist dort
jetzt gibt sie
keinerlei wirklich wirksame überprüfungs
mechanismen vor
ob das in der zukunft möglich wäre es
eine andere frage aber solange nordkorea
atomwaffen hat und sein land komplett
abschließt und niemanden dort hinein
schauen lässt und nicht mal die
amerikanischen nachrichtendienste wissen
wieviel atomwaffen hat nordkorea
eigentlich wie will ich da die komplette
nukleare abrüstung überprüfen und dann
sind wir wieder in der situation die bei
945 hatten
wer möchte in einer welt leben in dem es
keine atomwaffen gibt außer bei kim jong
hun ja also ich nicht aber ich meine
sozusagen das motiv der abschreckung
dass es gar nicht so einen angriff kommt
das ist natürlich paradox es gibt ein
schönes zitat von dem physiker und
philosophen carl friedrich von
weizsäcker von 19 57 und der schreibt
die großen bomben erfüllen ihren zweck
nämlich den frieden und die freiheit zu
schützen nur wenn sie nie fallen
sie erfüllen diesen zweck aber nicht
wenn jedermann weiß dass sie nie fahren
werden eben deshalb besteht die gefahr
dass sie eines tages wirklich fahren
werden
das ist schon das paradoxe die jahre
abschrecken kann nur funktionieren wenn
man unsicher ist ob sie funktioniert ja
weil wenn alle wissen dass sie
funktioniert kann man ja große
konventionelle kriege führen genau ja
auch verhindern niemand die atombombe
einsetzen wird
weil er kein interesse daran und oft
nach gehört ein atomkrieg hat keinen
gewinner kann keine gewinner haben aber
das ist heute wahrscheinlich anders mit
den moderneren waffen ja nicht nur mit
den moderneren waffen das ist auch ein
aspekt aber ich denke ein wichtigerer
aspekt ist dass sich vor allem russen
auch chinesen auf die möglichkeit von
regionalen kriegen ein einlassen und
darüber nachdenken wie man diese
regionalen kriege unter der androhung
des eigenen einsatzes von atomwaffen
gewinnen kann
ich glaube das ist die größte
herausforderung neben taiwan hatte ich
vorhin genannt als eine möglichkeit wo
es zu einer nuklearen eskalation kommt
das baltikum ist ein anderes thema das
ist konventionell für die nato nur
schwer zu verteidigen die russen haben
eine massive überlegenheit
bei nicht- strategischen atomwaffen und
das könnte dazu führen dass die
russische seite in einer solchen
situation den einsatz von atomwaffen an
droht und die nato dann vor der
situation steht entweder groß nuklear zu
eskalieren oder die niederlage
einzugestehen und dann erst das 2
es gibt leider genug leute die herrn
putin beraten und die sagen der westen
ist dekadent die werden die niederlage
eingestehen
das könnte aber eine fehlkalkulation
sein ich habe am anfang der sendung
gesagt es steht 1 100 sekunden vor zwölf
die weltuntergangsuhr und in der
geschichte wenn man zurückblickt gab es
immer auch mal wieder moment im kalten
krieg oder bürgerkrieg zu einem heißen
krieg wurde nämlich etwa in der
kubakrise 19 62 schauen wir uns dazu
eine ganz spezielle filmsequenz an ein
sogenanntes anime teil der
webdokumentation nuklear games eine
geschichte nicht nur zum anschauen
sondern auch zum mitlesen erzählt im
stil eines manga comic passend zu japan
lassen sie sich auf dieses experiment
ahlen rücken sie etwas näher an den
bildschirm und tauchen sie ein
karibik oktober 1962 höhepunkt der
kubakrise die sowjetunion hat heimlich
atomraketen nach kuba geschmuggelt
präsident john f kennedy kündigt ein
embargo die airforce überwacht das
embargo plötzlich entdecken die speer
ein sowjetisches u-boot das aufgetaucht
war um seine batterien zu laden
an bord der b 59 unterhalten sich gerade
flotten kommandant was cilia popov und
bordkommandant valentin sawicki
[Musik]
was niemand weiß die b 59 gehört zu
einer flotte von vier u-booten die die
sowjets heimlich in die karibik
geschickt hatten
zur unterstützung von revolutionsführer
fidel castro
[Musik]
auf dem radar entdecken die
amerikanischen aufklärer das abgetauchte
u-boot erneut
die amerikaner wollen das sowjetische u
boot zum auftauchen zwingen
dessen besatzung hatte wegen der grossen
distanz seit tagen keinen kontakt mehr
zum ausbau gehabt an bord des u boots
liegen die nerven deshalb zunehmend
blank bei 60 grad celsius
was die amerikaner nicht wissen die
sowjets haben einen neu entwickelten
atom torpedo an bord
flotten kommen landhof interveniert er
will zuerst moskau konsultieren
bordkommandant sawicki gibt trotzdem den
befehl zum einsatz
flotten kommandant archos greift erneut
ein er hat am eigenen leib einen unfall
auf einem atom-u-boot miterlebt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
flatten kommandant vasilakis setzt sich
schließlich durch die vier u-boote
lassen sich identifizieren und kehren in
ihre sowjetische heimat zurück
die amerikaner haben das embargo
durchgesetzt der dritte weltkrieg und
ein wahrscheinliches nukleares inferno
wurden abgewendet flotten kommandant
vasiliev und seine mannschaft werden
nach ihrer rückkehr in die heimat für
ihr verhalten kritisiert ihnen wird
feigheit vor dem feind vorgeworfen
actos geschichte wurde lange
totgeschwiegen er selber hat sie mit ins
grab genommen
die pop stirbt 1998 möglicherweise an
spätfolgen der verstrahlung beim unfall
auf dem atom u boot k 19
ein paar jahre später geht der u boot
funker der b 59 mit der geschichte an
die öffentlichkeit
johanna bewegende geschichte die zum
glück noch mal gut ausgegangen ist aber
die welt hing am seidenen faden könnte
man vielleicht sagen im film gesagt es
werde zu einem dritten weltkrieg
gekommen sehen sie das auch so ist
natürlich spekulation aber die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass es zu einer
nuklearen eskalation gekommen wäre also
das heißt dass auch die amerikaner im
verlauf dieses dann entstehen dann oder
sich weiter entwickelnden konfliktes
atomwaffen eingesetzt hätten die wäre da
gewesen also kennedy war ja ohnehin in
der krise sehr stark auch unter dem
druck der militärs hat die politische
kontrolle aber sehr gut im laufe dieser
krise aufrecht erhalten aber wenn das
passiert wäre dann wenn die wenn die
server jetzt selber atomwaffen
eingesetzt hätten dann wäre eine
eskalation möglich gewesen aber die
kubakrise selber hatte eigentlich eine
auch eine positive wirkung also das war
sozusagen der an der beginn der der
rüstungskontrolle der bemühungen zum
beispiel durch sogenannte rote telefone
kommunikationsmöglichkeiten in krisen zu
schaffen und dann später auch ende der
60er jahre begann die ersten
verhandlungen zwischen sowjets und
amerikanern über die begrenzung von von
rüstungen
da hatte ich sehr viel transparenz und
vertrauen auch gebildet im verlaufe
dieser phase des kalten krieges und
eines problem was wir eben heute haben
ist diese ganze rüstungskontrolle
architektur mit verschiedenen verträgen
bis auf ein abkommen nämlich das new
start abkommen das jetzt noch mal von
brighton und putin um fünf jahre
verlängert worden ist dass diese
rüstungskontrolle architektur mehr oder
weniger zusammen bricht der vertrag für
europa sehr wichtig wo es um das verbot
von mittelstreckenwaffen ging ist jetzt
gekündigt worden von von trump weil die
russen sich nicht daran gehalten hatten
und das ist natürlich ein weiteres
element warum diese anfangs frage von
ihnen wo stehen wir in bezug auf die
gefährlichkeit und die
wahrscheinlichkeit von atom kriegen so
zu beantworten ist dass die lage sich
sehr gefährlich entwickelt weil wir
diese kooperativen elemente wo beide
seiten oder mehrere seiten sich jetzt
bemühen die gefahren einzudämmen nicht
mehr da ist genau über diese
rüstungskontrolle werden wir am schluss
der sendung noch mal sprechen was so die
horizonte sind wie man jetzt zu dieser
abrüstung und vielleicht einer
nuklearfreien welt kommen könnte
in der vorbereitung fand ich interessant
zu erfahren dass auch die schweiz einmal
die idee hatte eine eigene atombombe zu
konstruieren zu bauen und ich habe damit
darüber im vorfeld mit dem srf
wissenschaftsredakteur daniel theis
gesprochen und ihn gefragt was die
schweiz denn dazu bewogen hat eine
eigene atombombe zu bauen
wer nach dem zweiten weltkrieg sah sich
westeuropa und damit auch die schweiz
stark bedroht von der sowjetunion von
der streitmacht dort mit den atomwaffen
und deshalb wurden in der schweiz eigene
pläne gemacht der bundesrat setzte eine
studienkommission ein die studien
kommission für atomenergie das war kurz
nach dem krieg und die sollte eigentlich
die zivile nutzung der atomenergie
vorantreiben aber hat im geheimen eben
auch pläne für eine schweizer atombombe
verfolgt offen darüber geredet wurde
aber erst wirklich nach der
niederschlagung des ungarn aufstandes
das war nämlich ein schlüsselmoment auch
wieder weil die sowjetische bedrohung
wurde richtig spürbar
und dann hatten schweizer exponenten des
schweizer militärs haben gesagt ja wir
wollen so eine bombe haben wir wollen
die in einem
flugzeug packen können und nach moskau
fliegen und die da abwerfen und einige
jahre später hat auch der bundesrat
offiziell noch davon gesprochen dass er
atomwaffen haben möchte ja letztlich hat
es dann doch nicht geklappt mit der
eigenen atombombe warum eigentlich nicht
eine atombombe zu bauen das ist
technisch sehr anspruchsvoll
es braucht bestimmte isotope von rahn
und plutonium und die liegen nicht
einfach so am auf dem boden herum
sondern die muss man entweder mit
zentrifugen im fall von uran kompliziert
gewinnen oder erblühten im fall von
plutonium und das macht man am
einfachsten indem man das in einem
atomreaktor macht das ist auch der grund
warum die entwicklung von atombomben und
atomreaktoren die strom liefern
irgendwie nahe zusammen sind zumindest
damals in dieser anfangszeit
die schweiz hatte nur ansatzweise solche
anlagen wir hatten ein
eine versuchsanlage die ist theorie das
war ein schwerwasserreaktor mit dem
theoretisch plutonium
er brütet werden konnte das wurde aber
nie wirklich gemacht und die schweiz hat
zwar versucht die eigene reaktortechnik
vorwärts zu treiben
sie hat noch einen weiteren größeren
reaktor gebaut in lösung war das der ist
kurze zeit nach kurzer betriebszeit gab
es darüber einen desaströsen unfall und
die anlage wurde stillgelegt das heißt
die schweizer eigene reaktortechnik die
kam nie wirklich zum fliegen obwohl man
das versucht hatte und für die großen
kommerziellen reaktoren die wir auch
heute noch haben wurde amerikanische
technik gekauft und damit auch die
bedingungen eigentlich dass man aus
diesen reaktoren nichts gewinnt was mit
atomwaffen zu tun hat und die schweiz
wurde auch von den großmächten von den
supermächten ein bisschen gezwungen
schon fast den atomwaffensperrvertrag zu
unterzeichnen
also salopp gesagt könnte man sagen die
schweiz hat es nicht geschafft mit
eigener technik und niemand sollte der
schweiz atomwaffen geben also blieb
dabei es gab keine schweizer atombombe
ja daniel theis spricht das an
im video das die verschränkung zwischen
atomkraft und atombombe von der technik
her eigentlich funktionieren atomwaffen
ja durch kernspaltung
das ist eine unkontrollierte
kettenreaktion von kernspaltungen die da
stattfindet und bei der kernenergie
versucht man diesen prozess zu
kontrollieren aber es ist ein und
derselbe prozess eigentlich den den es
da gibt um strom zu erzeugen auf der
einen seite und auf der anderen seite um
kriege zu führen oder die welt in die
luft zu jagen
ist das nicht ein sinnbild für die
ambivalenz die mehrdeutigkeit der
technik generell ja ganz sicher also es
hat man natürlich mit mit jeder
technischen entwicklung dass man die
unterschiedlich einsetzen kann und dem
fall hat man diese energieproduktion und
man kann die energie haut auch störe ich
nutzen oder konstrukten in indien
und dass das ist das klassische to use
phänomen das man auch schon mit einem
werkzeug hat ein werkzeug das sehr
nützlich ist wie ein messer kann man
halt auch für dinge nutzen die sehr
problematisch sind
das ist aber glaube ich darf kein grund
sein um gegen eine technik ich glaube
dass die diskussion muss dann wirklich
auch im einsatz und eine
weiterentwicklung in die
unterschiedlichen richtungen stattfinden
häufig ist es ja schon auch so dass es
dann je nachdem in welchen
anwendungsbereiches geht
unterschiedlichen spezialisierungen gibt
aber ist die technik immer so neutral
wie sie das jetzt skizzieren dass man
sie für das gute und schlechte verwenden
kann ist manchmal nicht auch in der
technik selbst eine gewisse tendenz
schon drin eine eigendynamik und das
gibt es die möglichkeit nachkommen das
glaube ich auf jeden fall oder das eine
technik wie eine atombombe natürlich
neue zerstörungs möglichkeiten mit sich
bringt also dass das auf jeden fall aber
natürlich ist ist das problem der
technik ist schlussendlich was damit
gemacht wird was damit entwickelt wird
aber ich glaube trotzdem man muss auch
aufpassen dass es häufig danach sahen
einen ein selbstläufer gibt oder man
entwickelt eine technik immer weiter und
immer weiter und sie geht in eine
richtung die man ursprünglich gar nicht
vorgesehen hat und dafür glaube ich
brauche es auch in der wissenschaft ein
ein großes bewusstsein dass man auch in
dem sie neben dieses diesen selbstläufer
unterbrechen kann und sich selbst auch
manchmal fragt was tue ich eigentlich
hier wohin will ich eigentlich mit
dieser entwicklung und wohin geht sie
oder was ist möglich
also ich glaube dieses bewusstsein muss
schon ganz früh in der forschung muss
dass muss das geschäft muss das gestärkt
werden also das heißt bei den
physikerinnen und physikern zum beispiel
dieses prinzip der kernsparte wurde 1938
von den physikern otto hahn und fritz
straßmann entdeckt würden sie sagen die
hatten schon die verantwortung darüber
nachzudenken was für folgen das
möglicherweise haben könnte diese
entdeckung also viele diese fische haben
sich ja dann auch geäußert und haben
sehr viel darüber nachgedacht
ja ich denke schon dass die gedanken
kommen ist das heißt nicht dass man
aufhören muss das heißt nicht dass man
einen teil der schuld trägt aber die
entwicklung zu begleiten das war ja dann
auch im kalten krieg haben viele
biografische klasse aktiv gewarnt gegen
dieses dieses weltgrößten weil sie sich
auch in der verantwortung gefühlt haben
weil sie das problem verstehen und und
dass das hier eine verantwortung waren
ist das ist nicht das gleiche wie eine
schuld und das und das ist eine rolle
die der vorschau haben wissensvorsprung
genau wie orange china weil sie sehen
was passiert bevor es uns bekannt ist
und dass man die diskussion auch
frühzeitig frühzeitig würde dieses
bewusstsein ist aber schon auch das
hatten wir wohl auch besprochen
in unterschiedlichen
wissenschaftsbereichen dass das auch
schon junge forscher eben mit diesen
fragen konfrontiert werden und dass man
das diskutiert
jetzt wird er heute wieder an neuen
kernkraftwerken geforscht es werden
moderne kern kernkraftwerke gebaut
gerade in den usa wird da viel
investiert joe biden aber bill gates
investieren viel geld da tränen kleine
modulare kernkraftwerke wenn man derzeit
guckt auf die auf die weltkarte dann ist
es so dass man sieht dass wir sehen hier
die karte
das immer noch erstaunlich viele länder
atomanlagen bauen die usa russland china
indien pakistan frankreich also die
schweiz deutschland ist ihr so nicht so
wirklich auf dem auf dem trend warum
denn dieser aufschwung der der
kernenergie freude platzes ich denke das
hat wieder nach diesen selbstläufer zu
tun oder man man ist da schon recht weit
man sieht die perspektive was da noch
möglich ist also auch mal weiter
es gibt schon auch eben ideen dass man
das damit möglichkeiten gäbe die solche
kernkraftwerke sicher zu machen und
woran mag das problem des abfalls zu
minimieren indem man eben länger nutzen
kann das ist das nicht mehr so dass das
opfer produkt eine viel kleinere
halbwertszeit hätte aber ich glaube da
braucht es dann wie auch druck eben aus
diesen dieser selbstläufer linie
auszusteigen wirklich andere dinge
auszuprobieren
langfristig muss man sich diese option
im das je nach dem in unserer energie
konsum so weiter steigt ist sich auch
diese forschung dass man auch die option
ist ganz außer acht lässt da scheint mir
aus meiner perspektive sinnvoll aber es
soll und auf mich die schweiz den
schweizerischen medien auch richtig
nicht die priorität sein im moment so
dass man sich auch den druck selbst
schafft wirklich andere innovationen so
werden weil der mensch ist so er
funktioniert so man braucht einen
gewissen druck um wirklich ganz neues zu
probieren aber einen großen vorteil
haben akw ist natürlich sie sind nicht
klimaschädlich und das ist ein argument
das oft auch gebraucht wird in der
gegenwart um die klimakatastrophe zu
vermeiden oder zu entschärfen besser
kernkraft zu verwenden anstatt kohle öl
und gas und so weiter was halten sie
denn von diesem argument das ist ein
sehr guter punkt also dass das ich glatt
geht die alternative kann nicht sein
dass man nur noch fossile energie nutzt
aber auch da muss man mit aufpassen dass
man nicht gegen diese dichotomie rein
gerät entweder das eine oder das andere
sondern dass man jetzt wirklich versucht
die miete auszubauen ich meine die
schweizer produziert sehr viel
erneuerbare energie wasserkraft ich
glaube im bereich solar ging es noch
sehr viel steigerung möglich und im
endeffekt muss auch ein druck da sein
unsere männer die zu konsum zu
überdenken also ich glaube das ist schon
auch ein wichtiger punkt dass man wenn
man hier eine eine kosten nutzen risiko
nutzen analyse macht und die risiken die
die auf eine uns nehmen für energie die
natürlich unterlegen vereinfacher
bequemer macht alles automatisiert
aberglaube dass sache das muss man eben
ihm in der innovationsphase rücksicht
muss was wollen die eigentlich wo soll
die zukünftige technische innovation hin
geht es darum noch mehr zu
automatisieren alles noch bequemer zum
auch noch einfacher zu machen ja oder
soll man gleich eben die die ganze
nation er ihm das ziel nachhaltigkeit
stecken und und da ja genau dann ist
immer die frage mit welchen risiken will
man auch leben also jede technik hat die
vor und nachteile sage ich jetzt mal
pauschal und bei der kernkraft ist das
sind
warum zwei risiken wenn ich das richtig
sehe also einerseits die endlagerung des
radioaktiven materials darüber werden
wir gleich noch reden dass andere das
unfallrisiko also wir reden jetzt zehn
jahre nach fukushima und die erste große
super katastrophe das super gau 1986 in
tschernobyl und wir schauen uns dazu
noch mal ein zweites anime einen zweiten
film an als der web druck & nuclear
games die geschichte dieser katastrophe
erzählt aus der sicht eines
feuerwehrmannes samstagmorgen 26 april
1986 ein uhr 24 der 25 jährige
feuerwehrmann was sie wird wegen eines
brandes ins nahe gelegene kernkraftwerk
von tschernobyl gerufen
seine frau ludmilla ahnt noch nichts
schlimmes
genauso wie die anderen bewohnerinnen
und bewohner der retortenstadt
präpariert
auch vassili und seine kollegen von der
werkfeuerwehr sind ahnungslos
die verantwortlichen haben von einer
normalen feuersbrunst gesprochen
die feuerwehrleute merken bald dass es
sich um mehr als nur ein feuer handelt
herumliegende grafit stücke aus dem
reaktorkern führend zu schrecklichen
verbrennungen durch die schutzkleidung
hindurch
bei tagesanbruch gelingt es den
feuerwehrleuten den brand im reaktor 4
des kernkraftwerks zu löschen
[Applaus]
die feuerwehrleute werden sofort nach
moskau gebracht in eine klinik für
strahlenschäden
niemand darf davon wissen noch versuchen
die behörden den bau zu verheimlichen
die schwangere ludmilla lässt nicht
locker und macht sich auf die suche nach
ihrem verschollenen ehemann ein paar
tage später findet sie vassili im geheim
spital nummer sechs ihrem mann und
seinen kollegen scheint es zum glück
ganz gut zu gehen
die zuständige chefärztin macht ludmilla
klare vorschriften
ludmilla ignoriert diese sie umarmt
ihren mann vassili der ihr unversehrt
scheint ein paar tage später liegt
vassili im sterben
er und seine kollegen von der feuerwehr
waren riesigen strahlendosen ausgesetzt
wegen der hohen strahlenwerte will die
sterbenden niemand fliegen
[Musik]
ludmilla lässt sich nicht vertreiben
trotz ihrer schwangerschaft sie bleibt
an der seite ihres mannes bis zum
bitteren ende
[Musik]
wasili erhält posthum einen orden der
sowjetunion danach werden die
feuerwehrleute als sondermüll an einem
geheimen ort begraben
am 13 juli bringt ludmilla eine tochter
zur welt sie nennt sie natascha wie sie
es mit ihrem mann vassili besprochen hat
der säugling weist jedoch schwerer
strahlenschäden auf und lebt nur gerade
vier stunden die mutter setzt durch dass
die tochter zum vater ins grab gelegt
wird ja eine sehr bewegende tragische
geschichte von vielen schicksalen wenn
man auf die chaotische hat sieht man
auch wie sich diese radioaktivitäts
wolke nach dieser katastrophe dann
ausgebreitet hat wir sehen dass hier als
diese animierten karte die auch auf der
web dokumentation nuclear games auf der
website zu sehen ist er jetzt streitet
man sich ja über die konkreten
gesundheitlichen folgen dieser
katastrophe bis heute was kann man mit
sicherheit sagen ja ich bin jetzt in dem
sinn keine kenneth medizinerin ab es ist
unbestritten dass diese strahlung krebs
ursache aber krebs ist eine der
häufigsten todesursachen in unserer
gesellschaft und ungenauen zu sagen
welche krebserkrankung jetzt auf diese
auf diese damalige strahlung
zurückzuführen ist bis in die schweiz
aber auch mehr näher an tschernobyl
das ist sehr schwierig das was dazu
führt dass man eben keine klaren zahlen
hat und wir haben gerne zahlen um einen
schaden ganz konkret der quantifizierung
zu können aber die zahl der todesopfer
von tschernobyl dass das variiert von
von es gibt 30 diesen ziemlich
unbestritten am unfall selbst wo auch
die diese feuerwehrmänner dazu gehören
aber dann markiert die zahl bis wenig
über 30 bis zu 100.000 einfach weil weil
das sehr schwierig ist ich habe auch
zahlen von der schweiz gelesen dass es
leute das gesagte anhand basierend auf
der der strahlung die man hier hatte
berechnet man das vielleicht ungefähr
200 todesfälle darauf zurückzuführen
sein könnten
aber das in einer zeit in der man fast
eine halbe mio
krebs stelle hatte so etwas ist
natürlich biologisch nicht nur
nachweisbar und ist ist auch einfach
sehr sehr schwierig zu fassen aber
unbestritten ist dass das extrem
gesundheitsschädlich ist und auch noch
die lucky die konsequenzen vor ort dass
eine ganze region evakuiert werden
musste und nicht mehr bewohnt werden
kann also dass das ist unbestritten
und wir alle kennen nach diese
jodtabletten die wir zu hause haben
für den ernstfall für die für die
katastrophe und die das risiko zu
minimieren dass es zwischen diesen krebs
in anderem kontext krebs kommt die
risiken der technik jetzt der ak w s wie
gewichten sie das als ethikerin auch
noch mit diesem unwissen sie haben
gesagt man weiß einfach sehr wenig auch
noch darüber
trotzdem müssen wir entscheiden mit
welchen energie energien gehen wir in
die zukunft gibt es aus ethischer sicht
so grundprinzipien der risiko ethik an
die man sich halten können
ja da gibt sicher verschiedenen seiten
der eine ansatz ist eine kosten nutzen
analyse dazu muss natürlich auch hier
müssen die kosten irgendwie fassbar sein
ich glaube aber nicht dass man das ist
im rhein konnte natürlich machen kann
ich glaube man kann hier sagen die
kosten die sind potenziell sehr hoch
aber die wahrscheinlichkeit ist sehr
klein und das hat man bei risiko auch
risiko wird häufig berechnet aus einer
ein dass die multiplikation zwischen der
eintretens wahrscheinlichkeit und dem
eintretens ausmaß und haben eine sehr
kleine wahrscheinlichkeit und ein großes
ausmaß für die leute vor ort und das ist
ein schöner vergleich zu zum klima
probleme oder dort hat man eine sehr
große wahrscheinlichkeit man kann schon
fast sagen eine sicherheit dass es sind
das eine erwärmung stattfindet aber für
unsere generation hier in der schweiz
wird diese auswirkung noch nicht so groß
sein von daher hat man ein ganz anderes
risiko eine unglaublich hohe
wahrscheinlichkeit eingriff für uns hier
kleineres aus während man bei dem bei
der beim reaktorunfall eine sehr kleine
wahrscheinlichkeit ein sehr großes
ausmaß hat wie geht man damit um das ist
auch psychologisch eine ganz
unterschiedliche herausforderung wobei
man natürlich auch sagen muss eben beim
klima
hat man dann auch die ganzen
auswirkungen global und auch in der zeit
dimension die dann auch ein riesengroßes
ausmaß dort haben aber jetzt im umgang
mit den risiken im einerseits hat man
diese kosten nutzen analysen und sagt
ihm der nutzen ist die energie die
kosten sind diese risiken wollen wir
wirklich für die energie die wir
vielleicht auch anders gewinnen könnten
im besten fahren diese risiken in kauf
nehmen eine ananas betrieb ist das
vorsorgeprinzip das ist ein sehr
schwieriges bringt sie beide sehr
unterschiedlich definiert werde ich
vorsorge bringt sie das vorsorgeprinzip
genau als meine perspektive die
sinnvollste definition da ist dass man
das als ein prinzip versteht dass uns
etwas zu umgang mit unwissen sagt also
zu dass es in die aufmerksamkeit darauf
richtet dass es gewisse unsicherheiten
gibt und dass man diese unsicherheit mit
berücksichtigen muss das heißt dass man
mehr wissen ansammeln muss um diese
unsicherheiten zu dessen zu minimieren
dass man teilweise aber auch
unterschiedliche strategien entwickeln
muss das macht unsicherheit besser
verstehen muss
teilweise sind das auch unsicherheiten
die dann etwas mit der anwendung zu tun
haben und nicht mehr rein technisch sind
daneben auch andere interessensgruppen
an experten einbezogen werden müssen und
in dem sind kann ein solches prinzip
helfen damit umzugehen
ich denke das vorsorgeprinzip als eine
entscheidungs prinzip halte ich
persönlich für sehr schwierig das wäre
eine idee die auch zurückgeht als
philosophen hans jonas der ach so was
gesagt hat versuche den worst case zu zu
vermeiden also wenn wenn ich bin eine
entscheidung eine mögliche folge davon
sehr sehr schlecht ist untergang der
menschheit zum beispiel dann sollte ich
diese option sich einig werden egal wie
unwahrscheinlich ist dieser fall ist
etwas einfach zusammengefasst sondern
aber das ist ja genau aber das hat ein
wirklich so ein veto prinzip ja aber
dass das eben dass das mag in ganz
extremen fällen macht das macht mag das
hilfreich sein aber in den meisten
fällen ist es nicht eine frage des
absoluten ja absolut nein und wenn man
natürlich immer vom schlimmsten fall
man kann sich immer
ein horror szenario vorstellen im
endeffekt kann man dann nichts mehr
machen also geht also das darf man auch
nicht blauäugig sein jede
energieproduktion kommt ein problem also
die lösung die einfach problem
die gibt es nicht möchte ist noch hat
die zweite problematik dass das zweite
risiko neben dem umfang nämlich die die
endlagerung von diesem material das man
irgendwie unter die erde verstauen muss
für tausende von mir von von jahren
strahlt das ja weiter und es ist
interessant in finnland wird jetzt das
erste große nuklearen endlager gebaut
es kostet 3 milliarden franken 77
kilometer langes tunnelsystem in granit
5000 tonnen atommüll soll das
beherbergen der dann tausende von jahren
noch weiter strahlen wir schauen uns
dazu einen beitrag
seit 2004 wird gebaut
in einem solchen schacht mehr als 400
meter unter der erde sollen die
einzelnen brennstäbe beerdigt werden und
das nicht nur für ein paar sondern
gleich für viele tausend jahre das
sicherheitskonzept kann man mit dem
eines flugzeuges vergleichen
es hat vier turbinen wenn einer ausfällt
ist das noch kein problem wenn die
zweite kaputt geht kommt man immer noch
runter wenn drei turbinen ausfallen wird
es schwierig aber der pilot kann das
flugzeug wahrscheinlich noch landen mit
unseren verschiedenen
sicherheitsbarrieren dürfte nichts
passieren
hallo kleine höhle nennen sie das
endlager mit gigantischen ausmaßen 1 77
km langes tunnelsystem tief im granit
5000 tonnen atommüll sollen hier ab 2020
eingelagert werden
spezielle kanister mit den
brennelementen werden jeweils in einem
eigenen schacht untergebracht die
schächte werden anschließend mit tonerde
versiegelt wenn das endlager voll
bestückt ist werden auch die anfangs
tunnel mit betonblocks wieder komplett
verschlossen
auch in der schweiz wird gegenwärtig
sondiert und nach einem möglichen
tiefenlager gesucht verantwortlich dafür
ist die nagra nationale genossenschaft
für die lagerung radioaktiver abfälle
und sie sitzen da im beirat entsorgung
wie weit ist in dieser prozess heute ja
ich muss vielleicht noch
ich bin nicht bei der nachgebaute beirat
ist dann beim beim bau vorerst beim
bundesamt für umwelt sehr wichtig weil
das das soll eben außerhalb der lager
seien also es gibt hier unterschiedliche
gremien im beim bund die dann die nagra
begleiten und beraten uns weiter und wir
beraten dem sind dass das bundesamt für
energie ja in der schweiz partner ist
dieser diese dieses verfahren ist in
gangs seit 13 jahren ungefähr
und das wird nach einem so das ziel lang
ich dieses verfahrens ist wirklich eine
eine prozedurale gerechtigkeit die
einzubauen und die große frage ist wo
soll man dieses lager bauen
wie entscheidet man das und da hat man
bevor man begonnen hat mit eigentlichen
suche hat man sich auf gewisse regeln
geeinigt das hat man auch workshops
gemacht man hat fuhren mit mit
bevölkerung gemacht es gab es einfach
nicht mehr übernehmen lösungsverfahren
der jede person sich äußern konnte zu
diesen regeln und daraus ist dann dieser
sachplan geologisches tiefenlager
entstanden der die regeln genau vorgibt
wie gesucht wird nach welchen kriterien
und die drei obersten zentralen punkte
in diesem verfahren sind einerseits
oberst die sicherheit also dass das
lager wir noch nicht an einem ort gebaut
wo es am wenigsten opposition gibt es
wird auch nicht dort gebaut wo es
wirtschaftlich in einem armen am besten
ist sondern es wird dort gebaut wo man
am sichersten diesen opfern überfordert
tausende von jahren lagern kann und der
zweite punkt ist partizipation das ist
auch wirklich ganz beeindruckend wie in
allen potenziellen regionen
dann gibt es so genannte
regionalkonferenzen das sind konferenzen
in der gehören vertreter der gemeinden
aber auch andere leute aus der
bevölkerung vertreten sind und die ihre
ihre kommentare geben zu für
unterschiedlichen schritten im verfahren
die die fragen stellen die auch gewisse
entscheidungsmöglichkeit haben wenn es
um raumplanerische dinge gibt
beispielsweise wo man einen eingang
hinstellen sollte für ein solches lager
um die dann aber diese ganze information
an die bevölkerung fließen lassen
und damit ist demnach ein dritter punkt
die transparenz extrem wichtig und ich
und das ist bei solchen prozeduren
absolut zentral das ging dann klar ist
was passiert welche daten vorhanden sind
wie entschieden wird wo man es den
prozess und dass das auch so vermittelt
wird dass das laien verstehen können und
das glaube ich funktioniert gerade mit
den regionalkonferenzen sehr sehr gut
dass ich habe von verschiedenen
fachleuten gehört dass sie beeindruckt
sind ab welchem niveau man mit den
leuten spricht das ist wirklich scheint
mir ein sowohl technisch als auch
politisch sehr komplizierten prozess zu
sein und das noch dialogisch zu
gestalten transparent zu gestalten ein
stichwort dass ich mit ihnen gerne
einfach besprechen würde
das ist so kompliziert ist zeigt sich
auch im finder und da wurde jetzt
nämlich der prozess der einlagerung
zeitpunkt wohl wurde nach hinten
verschoben weil es nicht geschafft haben
das ist jetzt glaube ich für 20 25 jahre
angedacht muss man reich noch
korrigieren zum ein spieler
die schweiz hat ja den und atomausstieg
beschlossen
bezieht aber immer noch ein drittel des
stroms beziehen wir schweizerinnen und
schweizer aus akw s das ist dann müssten
die frage wie man das jetzt ersetzt in
zukunft und darüber habe ich noch mal
mit daniel theis gesprochen in unserem
essen wissenschaftsexperte und
energieexperten und habe ihn gefragt wie
wir dann diesen ein drittel strom in
zukunft ersetzt
kurzfristig war nach der abschaltung von
mühleberg kann problemlos strom aus dem
ausland zugekauft werden
auf lange sicht muss sich die schweiz
fragen ob sie unabhängig werden will vom
ausland also wirklich eine eigene
stromproduktion und das was wegfällt
dann zu kompensieren
da gibt es die energiestrategie 2050 die
ist aber kein ganz konkret sagen wie das
aussehen soll
es gibt noch vieles was politisch
entschieden werden muss etwa bei der
wasserkraft die wasserkraft soll mehr
strom liefern in zukunft da wo viel
gegenwind auch gerade aus ökologischer
seite den steuererhöhungen die werden
bekämpft ihr bekämpft die
kleinwasserkraft weil sie besser
trockenlegt teilweise und insofern ist
da relativ unklar wie viel die
wasserkraft in zukunft wird liefern
können zusätzlich strom aus wind das ist
auch kein einfaches kapitel in der
schweiz da gibt es viel widerstand da
sehe ich auch nicht dass in kürzerer
zeit viele windturbinen gebaut werden
können jetzt dann gibt es noch
versprechen ganz weit weg am horizont
die aber noch nicht wirklich spruchreif
sind dass es die tiefengeothermie und
die fusionsenergie aber war es wirklich
jetzt schon da ist was funktioniert ist
die
solarenergie strom aus der sonne und auf
das setzt der bund jetzt auch es sollen
förderinstrumente verlängert werden neue
geschaffen werden so dass es sich auch
lohnt dazu investieren
und ich sehe das auch so dass der
solarstrom die realistische option ist
im moment um den kernkraft strom bereits
zu ersetzen
jetzt ist ja klar dass wir in zukunft
noch mehr strom brauchen werden zum
beispiel für elektroautos wie schaffen
wir dann das ganz ohne kernkraft der
strom wird wo die zentrale energieformen
der zukunft werden dass es mehr brauchen
wir auch league besser aber auf der hand
es ist einfach noch unklar wie viel das
sein wird das hängt davon ab was wird
alles elektrifiziert wie schnell geht
das hängt auch davon ab wie effizient
sind diese prozesse in zukunft klar ist
heute dass wir die autos elektrifizieren
werden dass wir die heizungen umbauen
wollen zu
wärmepumpen die mit strom funktionieren
was noch offen ist ist wie werden
lastwagen betrieben in zukunft werden
schiffe und flugzeuge angetrieben und
darum ist noch sehr unklar wie viel
strom in zukunft wirklich benötigt wird
der bund ist da recht konservative
schätzt dass bis im jahr 2050 nur zehn
prozent mehr nötig sind als jetzt
da gibt es auch andere schätzungen und
berechnungen die sagen nein es braucht
einen halt mal so viel wie jetzt das
sogar noch mehr
da gibt es wirklich noch ziemliche
unklarheiten letztlich darum auch sind
gewisse länder daran die kernkraft
weiter zu treiben etwa die usa die ist
wieder am forschen die dass eine neue
generation von kernkraftwerken kommen
es ist auch so dass weltweit über 50 im
bau sind im moment auch in europa das
heisst die schweiz ist der schwindler
gewissermaßen ein bisschen gegen den
trend der weltweit herrscht die eine die
ist gerade auch weil die rentabilität
immer ein thema ist bei der kernkraft
wo eben die sicherheit ein wichtiger
punkt ist also die sicherheit die
stimmen muss macht auch dass die
kernkraft teurer wird und da gibt es
einen plan dass man kleinere
kernkraftwerke bauen will
also statt ein großes auf die wiese
zustellen sollen
da viele kleine hinkommen das verteilt
das risiko und macht sie auch einfacher
zu bauen
ja das wird sich zeigen wie gut und wie
sicheren wie effizient die sind diese
kleineren neuen ach manchmal modular
genannten kraftwerke es interessant ist
eine parallele festzustellen also sowohl
bei der kernkraft wie bei den kernwaffen
weil ich das richtig verstehe man geht
zurück als kleinere wollen besser
kontrollieren kann die wirkung auch die
risiken bei den atomwaffen ist eine
ähnliche entwicklung wenn ich sie
richtig verstanden habe hin zu kleineren
waffen mit nichts an überdimensionalen
ausmaß das ist ein teil der entwicklung
der damit zusammenhängt dass man dadurch
die nukleare abschreckung stabiler
gestalten möchte wir hatten ja vorhin
schon über die grund- widersprüche der
nuklearen abschreckung gesprochen
also wenn eine seite oder wenn ein staat
in einem militärischen konflikte als
erster atomwaffen einsetzt und der
andere hat die keinerlei flexible
optionen was immer man jetzt bei
atomwaffen unter flexiblen optionen
verstehen möchte dann hat er ja nur die
möglichkeit entweder die niederlage
zuzugeben oder die welt untergehen zu
lassen und natürlich sind alle
atomwaffenstaaten immer schon bemüht
sich aus diesem dilemma zu befreien
indem sie eben atomwaffen entwickeln die
auch einsetzbar sein sollen aber nicht
um die tatsächlich einzusetzen um die
abschreckung das heißt die verhinderung
des einsatzes wahrscheinlicher zu machen
das ist eine sagen wir mal eine
gedankliche konstruktion die nicht
leicht nachvollziehbar ist wie aber
sozusagen bibliotheken füllt von von
leuten von strategen die sich in den
letzten jahrzehnten mit fragen von
l'oreal strategie und nuklearer
abschreckung beschäftigt haben schon
interessant wenn man sich die absoluten
zahlen anguckt der sprengköpfe dann
gehen die ja zurück wir haben noch eine
animierte grafik vorbereitet wieder aus
der webdokumentation und quelle games
die zeigt wie das im laufe des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts der zweiten
hälfte ab zugenommen und abgenommen hat
wir haben zuerst russland und die usa
gesehen im kalten krieg ganz hoch die
haben dann abgerüstet und jetzt hier
sieht man die ganz die eher kleineren
sage ich jetzt mal aber die kommen hat
jetzt auch nach wie man wie man sieht
sind indien nordkorea pakistan china
das heißt der eindruck täuscht auch wenn
man sich jetzt nur die zahlen anguckt
wie viele sprengköpfe in der welt ist zu
sehen es ist nicht relevant ob wir
35.000 wie früher oder 50.000 atomwaffen
haben oder wie heute 14.000 atomwaffen
wenn sie sich vorstellen wir reden über
tschernobyl wir reden über fukushima
sprechen wir über einen krieg zwischen
den usa und china und taiwan in dem
vielleicht 50 atomwaffen eingesetzt
werden
dann wird die welt hinterher nicht mehr
so aussehen wie jetzt trotzdem gab es
diesen absoluten abrüstungsprozess in
krieg der natürlich auch dann die die
sowjetunion finanziell auch mit in den
ruin getrieben hat das genau das hat
sicherlich unter anderem dazu
beigetragen dass der westen in der
nachrüstungsdebatte der 80er jahre
stabil geblieben ist und und nicht auf
die russischen oder die damals
sowjetischen drohungen und vorrichtungen
eingegangen
aber jetzt möchte ich von ihnen wissen
wie man dieses problem dann löst in
zukunft diese rüstungskontrolle haben
sie erwähnt was das genau heißt es gibt
ja auch ganz viele verträge von einem
atomwaffensperrvertrag zu diesem news
dort abkommen zwischen den usa und
rußland und so weiter
mittelstreckenraketen lösen verträge das
problem oder parks angel mittel
verantwortlich ganz diplomatisch mit ja
schön und zwar deswegen weil sie hatten
den atomwaffensperrvertrag genannt oder
nuklearen nichtverbreitungsvertrag dass
er als mann ein sehr wichtiges abkommen
das eine norm gegen die
weiterverbreitung er dazu gegen das
entstehen von immer mehr
kernwaffenstaaten
entwickelt hat nicht sehr alt 1900 1968
genau die schweiz ist dem auch
beigetreten das hatte übrigens dieser
vertrag hat nach meinem dafürhalten auch
viel damit zu tun warum die schweiz auf
ein eigenes atomwaffen projekt
verzichtet hat weil man wollte nicht bei
den bad guys sozusagen sein die die
atomwaffenstaaten sind dann mal wollte
bei den good guys sein die auf die
atomwaffen völkerrechtlich verbindlich
verzichtet
das hat man auch getan und das hat dazu
beigetragen dass wir uns dass wir heute
nur in anführungszeichen neuen
kernwaffenstaaten haben anstatt wie man
noch zu zeiten von kennedy erwartet hat
20 30 40 kernwaffenstaaten das ist sehr
wichtig dieser norm gegen die
weiterverbreitung von kernwaffen und das
andere ist was ist mit den staaten die
schon über kernwaffen verfügen wie kann
man dafür sorgen dass man die nukleare
abschreckung zwischen diesen
stabilisiert und zwar auf eine möglichst
niedrigem niveau wir sehen dann eben zu
der frage wie wir vorhin schon
diskutiert haben kann man
voraussetzungen schaffen atomwaffen
überhaupt ganz loszuwerden
und da braucht man ein abkommen das
wirklich die die überprüfung dass alle
atomwaffen vernichtet sind sicherstellen
kann aber auch dass diese zivilen
nutzung der kernenergie von der wir ja
gerade gehört haben dass sie wohl doch
in eine neue phase eintritt eben nicht
doch heimlich zur militärischen nutzung
missbraucht wird er brauchen wir stabile
überprüfungs mechanismen auf die sich
alle einlassen köster herr vorwurf an
iran zum beispiel oder bis wir dort sind
warten sie nicht auf godot sondern
versuchen über rüstungskontrolle die
nukleare abschreckung zu stabilisieren
und das wird nach meinem dafürhalten in
den kommenden jahren nicht mehr so viel
über verträge gehen sondern über nicht
vertragliche vereinbarung weil wir es
eben jetzt mit mehreren akteuren haben
nicht nur mit 2 früher gab war das
prinzip der parität also wir legen in
verträgen fest jeder darf so und so viel
jeder darf tausend sprengköpfe von denen
und tausend sprengköpfe von denen haben
das funktioniert in einer welt mit
mehreren kernwaffenstaaten als wirklich
nicht mehr und wir müssen viele nicht
nuklear museum gehört ja sagen alle
dürfen zehn haben
ja ich habe daraus ist gefragt im moment
ich meine das ist im moment das argument
der chinesin dass sie sagen würden wir
nehmen an der rüstungskontrolle nicht
teil weil wir haben ja noch viel weniger
als die russen und die amerikaner wollte
ernsthaft dass wir erst mal soweit
aufrüsten wie wo ihr schon seit um dann
mit euch rüstungskontrolle machen zu
gehör und umgekehrt sagen die russen und
die amerikaner also wir können jetzt uns
nicht auf das niveau von china begeben
um dann rüstungskontrolle machen zu
können
aber zurück zur frage wie können wir sie
gestalten ich denke es geht um ja es
geht um kommunikation es geht um den
austausch von vorstellungen über
bedrohung über die doktrin seminare es
geht um krisenbewältigung möglichkeiten
es geht darum vielleicht einseitig auf
bestimmte fähigkeiten zu verzichten und
die andere seite auch dazu zu animieren
und man muss nicht alles machen was man
was man machen kann also zum beispiel
kann man versuchen die kommandozentralen
nicht durch cyber-angriffe anzugreifen
und und diese dinge das ist glaube ich
in der zukunft sehr wichtig und weniger
so vertragliche dinge die wir so aus dem
kalten krieg kennen das muss sehr viel
flexibler werden es muss ein patchwork
von verschiedenen konzepten und von
verschiedenen instrumenten werden welche
rolle spielt die transparenz führt um
dieses vertrauen sag ich jetzt mal ab zu
generieren das es braucht wenn man nicht
ausser verträge abschieben kann
transparenz ist ist sehr sehr wichtig
aber die grundlage für dieses dafür dass
rüstungskontrolle erfolgreich werden
kann im sinne der weiteren auch
zukünftigen verhinderung von atom
kriegen ist die einsicht dass es in
einem nuklear zeitalter nur mit
gemeinsamer sicherheit funktionieren
kann und gemeinsame sicherheit bedeutet
dass sich bei allen maßnahmen die ich
ergreife um eine eigene sicherheit
sicherzustellen auch immer die
sicherheit dass anderen mit bedenke was
heißt das das bedeutet dass ich darauf
achten muss wenn ich ein ein angriff
system eine neue atomwaffen entwickle
die die nukleare zweit schlag fähigkeit
darüber hat mir vorhin gesprochen der
anderen seite unterlaufen kann dann
kommt die andere seite in einer krise
unter einem druck
seine waffen ihre waffen als erster
einzusetzen use the more you ist wie die
amerikaner sagen und das ist genau das
was wir natürlich in einer krise nicht
brauchen eine krise brauchen wir
entscheidungsträger politiker die zeit
haben kommunikation mit dem gegner
machen kann und so dass also eine solche
ungewollte schnelle nukleare eskalation
möglichst wenig wahrscheinlich ist
jetzt gibt es einen vorschlag haben sehr
philosophischen vorschlag der schon
ziemlich alt ist in dieser debatte
nämlich von dem britischen philosophen
bertrand russell
er sagte es geht nichts über eine
weltregierung wenn wir dieses problem
lösen wollen dann brauchen wir eine
aktions garanten sozusagen eine
weltregierung die die im besitz der
atomwaffen ist und sonst niemand sonst
bekommen wir gerade diese probleme von
abschreckung von aufrüstung und so
weiter was halten sie denn von diesem
jahr das land hat eine eine ein
vorschlag der schon sehr lange in der
diskussion ist aber wenn man sich die
welt ansieht dann kann man ja nicht
davon ausgehen dass wir auf dem weg zur
errichtung einer weltregion sind und das
ist ja leider modell ist in
wünschenswert erstrebenswert jetzt mal
und normativ wenn diese weltregierung
global demokratisch legitimiert ist ja
aber nicht wenn sie einen
überwachungsstaat ein diktatorischer
über wochen statt wie in china ist
natürlich schade platzes die frage an
sie von virgin rostocker vorschlag in
der idealen welt wäre das wunderbar aber
die eine regierung ist natürlich auch
ein potenzial dafür dass das man dann
eine diktatur hat eine weltdiktatur also
ich glaube wenn man das demokratisch
aber die uno waren versuche wurden
flächen die richtung und das dass die
dann wirklich auch macht hat dass das
ist praktisch sehr schwierig also ich
glaube da dhabi ist das ideal die
umsetzung des ideals wird da wohl
unmöglich das pärchen wichtig jetzt sind
wir schon fast am schluss der sendung
ich möchte mich dann einem zitat hören
und erfahren was sie was sie dazu meinen
es ist ein zitat von albert einstein der
auch mit die grundlagen gelegt hat für
diese technologie und er schreibt der
mensch
die atombombe aber keine maus der welt
würde eine mausefalle mäuse falle
konstruieren
wie deuten sie diesen satz oder was sagt
das über uns menschen aus ja ich glaube
dass sehr viele als ich gesehen wie
überfordert mit unseren eigenen
fähigkeiten oder wie wir sie nicht fähig
die fähigkeiten sinnvoll einzusetzen
wissen wissen punkt dass das entwicklung
von etwas neuem das ist das ist da sind
wir gut aber dann damit umzugehen
das ist das woran dann gleich und woran
scheitern wir jetzt zu viel gesagt aber
was unsere herausforderung ist haben die
mäuse also etwas uns voraus r trainer
naja mäuse bildet keine staaten und des
wegen der guten arbeit ein stein von dem
ich viele halter hatte an diesem
vielleicht an diesem beispiel ein
bisschen daneben gegriffen denn ich
glaube wenn heute staaten bilden würden
dann würden sie versuchen für die
anderen heute staatenlose freund zu ende
gehe und das ist eben das was wir als
menschen machen wir haben unseren
gesellschaftlichen gruppen also staaten
organisiert die ihre interessen kämpfen
und technologische entwicklungen sind
immer schon teil dieser dieser
auseinandersetzung gewesen und atomwaffe
ist natürlich sozusagen die spitze des
eisberges und um keine zweifel aufkommen
zu lassen auch ich wäre froh wenn wir
wege finden würden
diese spitze des eisberges im sinne der
atomwaffen komplett loszuwerden
aber es ist nicht einfach die
politischen voraussetzungen dafür zu
schaffen
aber man kann vielleicht hoffen dass uns
diese gefahr der auslöschung der
menschheit daran erinnert dass wir in
erster linie alle menschen sind und
nicht schweizerinnen oder schweizer oder
russen oder amerikaner das wird die
zukunft zeigen ich danke ihnen ganz
herzlich für dieses sehr dichte und
informative gespräche trainerfrage
platzes standen
ja danke ihnen fürs mit denken wenn sie
noch tiefer in die thematik eintauchen
wollen dann besuchen sie die webseite
nuclear games punkt nett und bleiben sie
voran denn die sternstunde kunst
zeitgleich einen berührenden film mit
dem titel stille über fukushima wie
künstler gegen das vergessen an kämpfen
nächste woche dann gehen wir ihm die
sommerpause von den sternstunden das
heißt wir zeigen ihnen in den kommenden
sieben wochen ein bestes unserer
sendungen in religion philosophie kunst
und musik wie immer sonntags von 10 bis
13 uhr
schauen sie also rein genießen sie den
sommer und bis bald
[Musik]